Narrator: One day,
a group of penguins were enjoying
themselves in the icy Tundra.
The penguins liked to swim and play and generally do
whatever it is most penguins do.
There was one particular penguin,
however,
who was different than the rest.
And he also was
the littlest penguin.
Mark: Hello Everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome to "The Littlest Penguin".
Now this is a game, about a penguin and
I'm sure it's going to be only lovely and amazing
And everything is gonna turn out great.
Up to Jump- Aww..
Oh, look at the tiny little jump!
Oh-ho-ho
Oh
Oh look at that!
What a little penguin!
Haaabooshky!
Oh! That don't work... apparently.
Hang on! Wai- wait a minute. I'm not a-
I'm not exactly a hundred percent sure
how to control the littlest penguin here.
Let me dive- oh wow that is scary.
*grunting noises*
Mark: There we go!
Narrator: The littlest penguin liked the other penguins
well and fine enough.
Albeit in small doses.
Mark: Of course.
Narrator: He was much more interested in going on adventures
Mark: Yes!
Narrator: And he hoped that today could possibly be
his best adventure yet.
Mark: I would agree.
Thank you so much for allowing
me to go on this epic, incredible adventure
*inhales*
Yeah, nothing dark and sinister *mumbles*
lurking around the corners here-
Whoa!
Hello! What the hell was that?
That was an awkward scene transition but okay..
Oh!
Hi!
Uh..
Narrator: Just then,
he discovered a very old,
very sick penguin
lying next to a large stone.
"Wont you please help me?",
cried out the old penguin.
"I am very sick and I am very old."
"Please."
"Won't you you help fulfill an old penguin's request?"
The littlest penguin agreed,
and was horrified by what
the old penguin said next.
"Bash my head in with this stone!"
"End my pain, littlest penguin!"
The littlest penguin did as he was told.
Mark: Uh.. don't I have any say in this matter?
Don't I?
Don't I get a little bit of
y'know input on the
adventure that's about to..
unfold before me?
Mark: Oh Gawd! I didn't do anything!
Narrator: Something began to stir inside
Mark: Oh no...
Narrator: The littlest penguin after that..
Narrator: Suddenly,
Narrator: a rush of emotions he had never known
Mark: *laughing* Oohhhhh noooo!!!
Narrator: filled him,
thrilled him, like nothing had ever done before.
Mark: *laugh-crying* Oh God..
Narrator: "This Feels like Heaven!",
Mark: Oh Jeez.
Narrator: cried out the littlest penguin,
Narrator: who set out freshly driven. Given new direction to his adventures.
"If killing just one penguin felt that good,"
Mark: Oh nooo
Narrator: He thought to himself.
Narrator: "I wonder how it would be
if I killed 10 penguins!"
And off he went
to test his theory.
Mark: Again, that way!
Oh, thank you for guiding me!
*laughing* I don't have any choice in the matter.
What happens if I go the other way?
Will I just kill those penguins?
Aw.. I'm just gonna go all the way you tell me to go
*laughing* Oh, no.
Oh, man.
Mark: Oh.
Narrator: The littlest penguin
Narrator: came upon a small group of his peers.
"This will do.",
he thought to himself,
picking up a club
that had been lying in the snow
Mark: *heavy breathing*
*laugh-crying*
*laughing* Ohhhh no...
*sniffles*
It's not such good narration!
*splat*
Mark: *laughing* Oh God! No!
Narrator: The first one went down quickly.
Narrator: Far easier than the littlest penguin
would have thought.
Narrator: This spooked the others,
but to his surprise,
the littlest penguin found, the more they ran
*squelch*
the greater his satisfaction
when he finally beat them down.
And beat them down he did!
*squelch*
Until the last of them
were reduced to little more
than a red stain in the snow.
Mark: Oh, my God. This is amazing
and horrifying- *trails off into laughter*
*splat*
It's just so satis- *trails off into laughter*
*laughing*
It's just a sudden thunk
Like, my God!
Just a club lying in the snow
randomly and sporadically and then..
Off to murder we go!
Ohh- Success!
I don't know if I'd call this a success,
but It's a thing!
Narrator: As he moved through the crowd in order to
reach the other side,
the littlest Penguin felt
the eyes upon him.
The other penguins began to grow weary of him,
shifting their gaze as he walked by.
"I do not like the way they stare at me!",
thought the littlest penguin.
"I do not like it one bit!"
"Perhaps, after I kill them all."
"I shall make a fine necklace"
"of their eyes!"
This thought occupied the littlest penguin
as the others
wobbled nervously around him.
"And perhaps,"
"A crown made from their beaks."
"So all can see and marvel at how beautiful I am!"
Mark: Okaay.
Alriiiight (;°Д°)
You think that they'd
be doing more than just giving me a shifty look?
Ohhhhh...
Ohh-ho-ho...
*chuckling* Geez...
Something uh..
something's slightly wrong
about this little penguin here.
Something uh-
something about being tiny and full of anger.
Something I can relate to
very much, just not to this level.
Oh boy..
Oh, good. I'm on a platform now.
Is this the stage I shall set for my
murderous campaign?
Oh... Oh!
Hi!
What the hell is-
Oh!
Oh cool!
An Arctic Research Center!
Whoa.. eh oh!
Ooh!
Narrator: This was more like it,
thought the littlest penguin
Mark: Oh!
Narrator: He could now return to the other penguins
and make good on his plans.
Mark: Look at that shaky-ass penguin
Narrator: The thought of which triggered an excitement
Narrator: He could hardly contain.
Mark: *laughing* Oh no!
*laughing*
Oh! look how shaky he is
Arrh! Get the penguin murderin' jigglin' fever!
He's- he's just a little dancy fool
Oh boy! Hi friends!!
HELLOO!!!
How are you doing?
Mark: Ohh! G-
Narrator: Faster and faster they fell and brilliant streaks
of crimson filled the air!
Again he would slash at them and again they would cry out!
Some attempted to vainly cram their entrails back inside
Others simply fell apart where they stood
Mark: Uuuh!
Narrator: The Littlest Penguin was thrilled. Oh, how he wished this moment could last forever!
The screams, the panic.
The Rapture that pulsed inside of him!
He could no sooner explain the magic behind his elation
Anymore than he could bring himself to stop.
Mark: Well!
Narrator: Not until every last penguin had been split apart...
Mark: *laughing* My goodness.
*laughing* This narrator is good by the way.
Oh, man I really like this story.
Definitely deserved a David Attenborough styled narration.
My goodness!
Well..
I hope that's the end because HOLY SHIT!
My God.
Oh, and that's the end!
Okay, David Mills,
Suits n Noos
Mark: Narration by Balthazar007
Narrator: When the last of them had finally stopped twitching.
Narrator: And he no longer felt the eyes upon him.
The littlest penguin stopped.
Breathing heavily, he surveyed the destruction
he had wrought.
They were all
so beautiful now.
Too beautiful, in fact.
The ecstasy felt
by the littlest penguin
slowly faded.
And an undeniable sense of
emptiness
Began to take its place
"Its not fair.",
Mark: Oh no..
Mark: Oh, no.
Narrator: he thought.
Narrator: "They are all so beautiful now."
Mark: Ohh noo!
Narrator: "Why can't I be beautiful like them?!"
Mark: Oh, God.
Narrator: "Why must I be the only one?!"
Narrator: "It isn't fair!!"
"It just isn't fair!!!"
The littlest penguin looked at the chainsaw.
Mark: Oh, no!
Narrator: The blood dripped off the teeth of the blade,
Narator: almost glistening in the moonlight
Mark: Oh God!
Narrator: Suddenly, the littlest penguin knew
how to feel
beautiful like the rest.
He knew then, what it was he must do...
*chainsaw sound*
*squelch*
Mark: Oh, God!!
Mark: Ohhh, God!
Ohhh, what a game!
*Narrator begins the story again*
Mark: Oh God! No!! Stop!!
Stop it!
I can't do it again!
Oh!! God, noo!
*narrator continues talking
Oh man! Oh, wow! Ohhh, wow!
What a game! What a game!!
Ohhhh, what a game!
Holy crap!
Ugh, I think it goes without saying don't go on
a chainsaw murder-suicide spree.
Don't do that.
Holy shit!
Aw, man. So like 10% of me actually enjoyed
that experience,
and then like the other 90% of me
wishes that I could wash my brain
so i never had to experience any of the
bullshit that I just saw.
But either way!
That was "The Littlest Penguin" so
Thank you everybody so much for watching,
for what it was!
*laughing* And I hope you got a laugh maybe?
I dont know so
Thank you again!
Let me know what you thought the deeper meaning
of this game
was, in the comments down below.
And as always,
I will see YOU in the next video!
BUH-Bye!
*Swag Outro*